I'm standing in a line at Trader Joe's
and I cannot believe I'm standing in a
line at Trader Joe's because I hate
Trader Joe's Trader Joe's is a [__]
grocery store it is a store where I can
go in and get hot dogs and buns but I
can't get the Doritos and the Diet Coke
or even the aluminum foil that I need to
put on the grill to cook the hot dogs
this is this is a grocery store that
requires you to have another grocery
store and that is [__] you walk in
and there's no aisles people just Mill
around like sheep and look for things
the the the registers are all equipped
with this Bell because if register 3
needs pennies they ring the bell cuz
everyone in the goddamn store needs to
know that register 3 needs pennies I
hate everything about this store and the
only reason I'm here is cuz my daughter
Clara loves the pizza bites and Charlie
loves the fish sticks and my wife likes
every godamn thing in this
store but I'm not even in the store I'm
outside the store in a socially
distanced line there's Gathering of
people because it is May of 2020 early
in the pandemic and the only thing
Trader Joe's does well is they only let
a few people into the store at a time so
at least it's safe so I'm standing in
this line for this store I hate for
people I love and I'm just trying to
keep the peace and I cannot cuz there is
a woman three people in front of me and
she's turned she's turned us into her
audience she is masked and she is
telling us how unfair it is that she's
being masked she cannot stand the fact
that she is is being forced to wear this
awful thing and there's all these things
I want to say to her cuz the one
superpower I have in this world is I
know the worst thing to say to someone
to make them feel bad I am the person at
CVS where if it's a long line and the
woman turns and says can you believe how
slow this cashier is I say in a very
loud voice why are you telling me how
Slow the cashier is she's right up there
you shouldn't talk behind her back and
my wife runs and the woman goes crazy at
the Patriots game when when the guy in
row 17 says hey take your hat off during
the national anthem to the poor guy in
row five who forgot I'm the guy who
turns around and says yeah hat police
that is a lot less disruptive than the
Hat I'm so glad you shouted at the man
during the national
anthem but my wife has told me I'm going
to get killed someday and she's asked me
to stop doing this so I'm letting the
lunatic scream about the mask and I look
at my phone and then she says the word
sacrifice she says she's making a great
sacrifice to have to go into the store
and something just snaps with me and I
look up and I say excuse me my father
was drafted and he had to fight in
Vietnam a war he did not want to fight
in he was exposed to agent orange he's
had four heart attacks and a heart
condition for all his life so when I go
home today I'm going to tell him about
the [__] hero I saw in the line who
made the sacrifice to wear the mask and
he's going to be amazed and she loses es
her
mind and she starts screaming for the
poor lady in the Trader Joe's line to
like have me arrested she wants to call
the police the guy behind me does not
help he says he didn't verbally abuse
you he called you a hero and that
doesn't help it doesn't help in any way
and I realize I've created these
situations that my wife warns me about
and I realize the only way to get out of
it is I have to leave so I tell the
Trader Joe's employe you don't need to
call the police I will leave I'll come
back later as I leave she says that's
right walk away and it is everything in
me to not turn around but I don't I get
in the car and I drive home and as I'm
driving I'm thinking about my wife and
how she says this is a bad thing to do
but I think it's not because there's
crazy people in the world that say
terrible things and good decent people
just have to listen to it all the time
and I just think maybe I can be the
crazy person that says the right thing
to the other crazy people so maybe the
next time she thinks about turning
around she'll think maybe I'm there and
maybe she'll
stop I'm a social justice Warrior that's
what I think I think that until I turn
onto my street and I see our house and
suddenly my body is filled with Glee I
can't wait to tell my wife what I just
did even though I know she's going to be
mad I am so excited about
it and it's that Glee that makes me
realize that I am not a social justice
Warrior
I just really love to yell at
people and make them feel bad when they
deserve to feel
bad as I'm driving towards my house I
realize that if the entire world
suddenly became universally kind and
benevolent I would be
upset I
would as I pull into my driveway I think
I am really no better than that lunatic
in the line because I am not shouting at
her because I want the World to Change
I'm shouting at her because I really
like shouting at terrible people and if
they were to all go
away that would be a sad day for
me so my wife is my wife is right as she
always is I need to shut my damn mouth
and move on in my life and be a better
person thank you
w